In the case of the ABO gene. The DNA
sequence will be transcribed into an RNA copy or
intermediate that will leave the nucleus, and go to
the cytoplasm. Where it will be translated by ribosomes
into protein. Now, we're about to dive deep into
these processes called transcription and translation. But first, we
should learn a bit more about this RNA copy,
that's so critical to the transfer of genetic information.
So if we follow the central dogma in
our example of blood type, our ABO gene, made
of DNA, is going to be turned into an ABO
RNA copy that can be trafficed to the cytoplasm.
And here, it will be turned into the ABO
protein by ribosomes. Now these two arrows here that
connect DNA to RNA and RNA to protein are
what we're about to dive deep into. These processes
are called transcription and translation, and by the
end of this lesson you'll see exactly how a
DNA code is turned into protein. But, for
us to dive deep into these processes, we really
need to understand a bit more about this
critical intermediate copy RNA. You'll remember from lesson two
that DNA is made of deoxynucleotides, and that's
what I'm showing you here. This is the chemistry,
the chemical structure we looked at when
we studied deoxynucleotides. And in this case, there's
an adenine, or an A as the
nitrogenous base that's attached. Now, RNA is, chemically
speaking, incredibly similar to DNA. In fact,
you should only be able to notice one
difference about the chemical structure of RNA compared
to DNA. RNA is made of nucleotides instead
of deoxynucleotides. And what I want you to try to do, select the
region that distinguishes DNA from RNA. Focus down here on the RNA
nucleotide and there are four regions to choose from. I want you
to pick the one that you think distinguishes it from the DNA deoxynucleotide.